this hospital
is in the problems of brazil's fight
against the new wave
of covet 19 one that's marketed by the
new variant p1
which is more aggressive than the
traditional coronavirus
the patient behind me is 22 years old
that's a new characteristic of kobe 19
here in port allegri more and more young
adults
are coming to the icu for treatment
here
we don't have enough space we don't have
enough people we don't have enough
equipment
so this is very frustrating for us
[Music]
[Music]
we believe this is the consequence of
the relaxation
of the mitigation strategies
of social distancing mask wearing
hand washing and basic measures that we
all learned
this room here has nine patients all of
them is icu
but there isn't enough ics in town
to take everybody in so they stay here
waiting
for a spot to open someone
those patients here they have been
improvised in this
semi pads they are hooked up
to oxygen but the books that are
supposed to fit
one patient aren't feeding
two or more here in the other side
you can see there are more people in the
same situation
and the the nurses and doctors here
they're doing their best to keep them
safe and
and treat them
and he does it so
[Music]
is
so now we have more people in their 30s
and 40s working-age people
who spend several days here
but the the staff tells me
that the rate of that is going up
and this patients with they will vary
one they tend to deteriorate very fast
this is extremely difficult for us
many patients came to the icu severely
ill
young patients dying it's not
uncommon to see parents and
kids hospitalized at the same time
dying one after the other
the situation has gotten worse uh the
the system is above capacity
and the doctors they estimate that the
situation
won't improve for the next several weeks